Prof: <<Video
clip>>
Well I think you got the
message.
I was actually going to show
you--this is the end of the
course.
Let me show you-- the beginning
of the course a little video,
but it was not in the right
format.
It shows our favorite dung
beetles copulating.
It's very graphic and it looks
just like humans,
the same rhythm and everything,
same motions.
The message of the course was,
this is what this course has
been about: start with insects
doing their thing and you end up
with humans doing their thing,
and in between nothing really
has changed.
The desire to engage in sex has
not changed, the quest for
status which determines sex.
We've had this over and over
again in the course and I hope
you realize by now that we've
discussed so much from the
Princeton project and other
projects how much social
acceptance is an important part
of fertility.
That people determine their own
fertility a lot because of what
is the acceptable norm in the
community.
Aside from the direct status of
having a lot of sons,
a big family gives you big
status, because of protection
and political power from the
large family and economic
security.
But it's all tied in with
status.
I think I mentioned to you
that, for instance in
Bangladesh,
they looked at fertility as a
function of religiosity and one
factor that had some effect was
the religiosity of the
particular family,
but the much bigger effect was
the religiosity of the
community.
It's all community acceptance.
It's all status and we
just--that comes directly from
the chimpanzees.
Of course you're aware that a
vast percentage of human
consumption, and the richer you
get the greater it is,
is status consumption.
The only difference between a
Mercedes and a Ford is basically
status and that kind of thing.
You've also seen that between
groups, the hostility between
groups has not--basically not
changed since chimpanzees.
The maltreatment of females,
the battering of females among
chimpanzees, the battering of
females among humans,
it's all stayed about the same.
I could have shown you that
video, you would have gotten the
message that--
and also why this is a biology
course,
or at least part of the reason,
is because the fundaments of
almost everything that we've
talked about are the same set of
behavioral propensities that are
apparently wired into us in some
way since our chimpanzee days.
This last--this video that you
did see,
the main point is that the
situation we are in now with
respect to population is totally
unprecedented in the history of
humanity,
there's just never been
anything like it.
You also know something about
the future--
Student:  Professor
Wyman, what year was that video
made?
Prof: What?
Student:  What year was
that video made?
Prof: That video was
made in--
I wrote that down--I think 1990
and the projections--
the actual numbers are pretty
good for their projection.
This is not a new video and
I'll show you the projection.
What's usually--these are the
projections that the UN has put
up for the future of population.
I think I showed you--early in
the course when I was discussing
quantitative methods,
the US Census Bureau projection
and that more or less mimics
this one.
The UN shows you that there's a
range,
they do not know what's going
to happen,
and so they give you a range of
possibilities for the future and
they do not call them
predictions at all,
they are simply projections.
Meaning that if X,
Y, Z, P or Q happens then this
will be the course of population
but they don't say which of
these things is going to happen,
if any of them.
What would you consider in
terms of say fertility?
What would you consider the
most conservative projection?
We know what's happened in the
past,
we know what the status is
today, how should we make our
future projection,
fertility staying the same,
fertility going up,
fertility going down?
Student:  Going down.
Prof: Thinks down, okay.
The UN, that's one of the
projections.
To my mind, the most
conservative projection is that
whatever we're at today that's
where we continue to be at.
In the sense,
that's what I think
conservative means that you
preserve what's been in the
past.
Well that's this projection
that the fertility that the
world is at today continues just
as it is.
The projection that's carried
out to 2050, and assuming that
stays where it is,
it will be--the population will
be 12 billion.
We're now about 6.7 billion.
The population will be not
quite double what we are now,
and rising ever faster.
That's the status quo
assumption.
The other assumptions are
optimistic that things
will--that fertility will come
down.
They're not unreasonable
assumptions and the reason why
some of you chose fertility
coming down because fertility
has been coming down.
It's not a crazy presumption,
but how much is going to come
down?
The UN gives you three
possibilities.
This projection,
which they call the high
projection, assumes that
fertility will come down another
half of a child.
Right now this was based on the
average fertility between 2000
and 2005,
it was about 2.8 children,
2.85 children,
and they're presuming in this
projection that it'll come down
another half a child for every--
the average for everyone on
earth to 2.35,
still above replacement level
fertility.
With that degree of optimism,
fertility comes down another
half a child,
population keeps increasing,
not as fast as this,
and by 2050 we get to roughly
11 billion and it's pretty much
going up in a straight line.
Now you can get a little bit
more optimistic and say,
well it's going to come down a
whole child's worth,
and that's this scenario here.
Now we're at 1.85,
the whole world has come down
to a quarter--
replacement level fertility,
as you know,
is 2.1 children,
so 1.85 is a quarter child
below replacement fertility.
You can decide for yourself how
much optimism is involved in
assuming that's going to happen.
If that's the case,
then population is like nine
billion in 2050,
and continuing up,
but clearly beginning to level
off at that time.
Now they get really optimistic
and they do this line.
And that's-- drops a child and
a half in this short amount of
time and goes down to 1.35
children,
way below replacement
fertility, and that's for the
whole world.
The assumptions are--these are
the UNs own statement of its
assumptions.
The constant fertility one,
fertility remains constant at
an average of more or less 2.8
or 2.85.
The high fertility assumption:
they're calling a reduction
from the fertility to 2.35
children.
Medium: 1.85. 1.35.
And then they have a really
miraculous assumption,
the instant replacement
assumption,
which they don't bother to
graph, which is each country,
immediately,
like tomorrow,
comes down to just the
birthrate that will replace its
population,
no more and no less.
What should we notice about
these things?
Obviously they're pretty
arbitrary assumptions.
No one knows what's going to
happen in the future.
No one claims to know what's
going to happen in the future
and it's a sign that we
don't--we just don't know enough
about this issue.
I mean I've told you a lot
of--the basic stuff that's
known.
We do not know enough to really
predict.
We asked, at the beginning of
the course, the middle and the
end of the course,
why has fertility been coming
down?
What are the determinants of
fertility?
You've gotten a whole lot of
answers.
If we knew the answer for sure
we would be able to predict,
but the future is not terribly
predictable.
These are projections not
predictions.
We've got a huge range there
from about eight billion to
about 12 billion,
that's an uncertainty,
and in the not terribly distant
future, of 50%.
That's a very large degree of
uncertainty.
Only the most optimistic
assumption, this last one,
only the most optimistic
projection has population
decreasing by 2050.
All the other assumptions show
it continuing to increase right
through 2050 with no statement
about what might or might not
happen beyond that.
In the medium variant,
this is the one that they call
the medium variant,
and because they use that word,
'medium' the press sort of
takes this as,
well, the most likely or
something.
The UN does not say anything
about the likelihood of any of
these estimates,
but take your choice.
In this rise that we're now
increasing at,
from 1970-up to 2007 ,
the average rise was about 78
million a year.
In this scenario by 2050
it's--the population is still
increasing by 30 million a year,
so that's their medium variant
as far out as they're willing to
even project,
not predict,
but even to project,
population is still increasing
by 30 million a year.
I keep saying these are
optimistic, remember none of
these assume that fertility
starts rising again.
We have indeed had a fall in
fertility.
And there are certainly reasons
to believe that if the world--
we've had a fall in fertility
and we've also had really rather
great progress in the world,
say since the end of World War
II.
I mean people are staying
alive, they're getting more
educated,
all parts of the world China,
India,
Indonesia, are just
unbelievably richer than they
used to be,
although still very poor and
pockets of real poverty exist.
I mean most of the world has
just improved tremendously,
both in the rich countries in
the West, Japan and in the poor
countries.
If you had to choose a date
that you would like to be alive,
but you couldn't choose who you
would be or where you would be,
the only reasonable date to
choose is now.
Because the average human being
on earth was worse,
worse, worse going back as far
as you want.
Now, if you could choose to be
a rich person,
that's maybe another story.
But if you just would be
randomly set down anywhere,
you would choose to be now.
So things have been getting
better, there's no question
about it.
If things continue to get
better--it's very reasonable to
presume that one of these,
maybe not this curve but one of
these more optimistic curves
might take place.
There are a lot of reasons why
things may not continue to get
better.
In the paper that --segments of
a paper that I wrote,
I list a number of them.
One that I listed there was an
economic collapse,
and I was talking about the
fairly small economic collapse
in Asia in 1997 which had just
happened at about that time.
I did not envision,
as did no one,
we have really now a global
kind of mega-crash and will we
recover or not,
who knows.
If economic progress is one of
the things that's required or
economic increase is one of
things that's required for
population to keep coming down,
then the global economy - who
knows what's going to happen.
It may very well turn around.
Religious fundamentalism is
another thing that we know.
It's not a particular religion
Christianity,
or Islam, or Judaism that
matters, but it is the
religiosity,
the degree to which people are
religious in whatever their
religious tradition is.
That latter makes a difference.
Religious fundamentalism is
basically increasing all across
the world, including the United
States, of course.
I read an article that,
Notre Dame is one of the great
Catholic Universities in America
and the priests,
a number of the priests--of the
order that founded Notre Dame
and still run it,
didn't want--President Obama
was invited to be the speaker at
graduation this year and the
priests didn't want him to be
because he's pro-abortion.
The conservatism in--at one end
of the spectrum of all religions
is there and increasing.
You see the Taliban is at one
end of the Islamic spectrum,
they are powerful--increasingly
powerful not only in Afghanistan
but now in Pakistan.
I don't know if you've been
reading the newspapers,
but they have now taken a
provincial big city or capital,
it was only like 13--30 miles
or something from Islamabad,
the capital of Pakistan so
they're increasing.
The population of Orthodox Jews
in Israel,
because they reproduce so much
faster than everyone else,
is very close to overtaking the
population of more moderate
Jews.
The Palestinians and the
Orthodox Jews in Israel are
having a battle to see who can
increase their fertility fast
enough to sort of out-reproduce
the other.
Another factor is the decline
in support for international
family programs.
As you're undoubtedly aware,
the population explosion which
was a very hot issue for the
press and for all kinds of
activist organizations in the
1960s and 1970s has just fallen
off the map.
Our own school of Environmental
Studies here,
Forestry.
does not have a single person
that pays any attention to human
population.
Courses like this are taught
basically nowhere else,
very few places elsewhere.
Environmental organizations
won't go near the population
issue and so government is not
under any pressure from the
citizens are reducing their
support of family planning.
This has already happened in
large degree,
as well as a lot of other good
programs,
and with the economic problems
of all governments now it's
going to fall even further.
Student:  Don't economic
problems exacerbate social
problems that governments would
want to control their fertility?
Prof: Very good
statement,
so do economic problems
exacerbate social problems so
that people will want to more
control their fertility?
Student:  Or the
government has a much more
vested interest to control
fertility.
Prof: What you say is
reasonable, but the opposite of
everything that we've sort of
said in the course.
When things are getting better,
that when people come from
being--
except for land availability
that--when infant mortality goes
down people reduce their
birthrate.
When education is available
people reduce their birthrate.
When countries get richer
So, No.
it's exactly the opposite
of--you should definitely take
that away from this course -
that good things happen when
things are already getting
better.
The reduction in fertility goes
along with, I didn't say caused,
but goes along with an
improvement in every kind of
condition that you can count.
When the economy goes--in the
1997 Asian crisis,
a lot of women working in the
cities and were working at
factories at sewing and so
forth,
not having children.
They lost their jobs,
they went back to the villages
and guess what they did?
They started having children.
It's improvement in a situation
that gets fertility down.
Student:  To go along
with that question,
maybe because it's more of a
short-term economic decline it's
more of a shock and more of a
depression that might cause
people to temporarily reduce--
Prof: Okay excellent,
her question was,
because this is a short term,
more of an economic shock than
a depression,
maybe people will temporarily
reduce their fertility.
That's a wonderful observation.
Economists really don't know
how to answer that.
When I started teaching this
course I taught--
co-taught it with a professor
of Economics and he was teaching
sort of the economic
determinism,
This is really what he believed.
He thought that,
as countries come up
economically,
fertility will come down more
or less automatically.
He was of the mind that
development is the best
contraceptive.
I've shown you--since then the
data has shown,
I think clearly shown,
that's not the case but that
was his belief then.
Then comes this 1997 economic
collapse in Asia and I go up to
this professor,
who I was not teaching with
anymore,
and I say--I say to him 'gee
here's this economic collapse in
Asia,
what do you think will happen?'
He said to me,
'I think fertility will go
down, which is what you're
saying because conditions are
getting worse,' and what you're
saying.
I was shocked and I said,
'but, and I won't tell you his
name, but that's exactly the
opposite of what you taught in
the course.'
What he said to me was,
'I think the theory is flexible
enough to accommodate both
results,' which means the theory
didn't predict anything.
If you can predict this and
then the opposite it doesn't
predict anything.
So we don't know that answer to
this.
I mean, first of all,
we don't know if this is a
temporary economic collapse.
I mean we hope it is,
but no guarantees.
The data to figure out the
difference between what's short
term, which is undefined,
and what's long term,
which is undefined,
very difficult to do;
you may be right you may be
wrong.
I think we just can't be
certain about that.
Of course, the other factor
which could cause things to go
to hell in a hand basket is
environmental collapse.
As the environment gets bad,
if things start getting used
up,
if people really start starving
or lose--
not having water or whatever
the environment will do first,
and we'll talk maybe a little
bit about what might happen
first.
Then, again,
things could go backwards very,
very fast.
None of this is--are
predictions that I'm saying.
I'm just saying that here's all
this optimism,
all of these except the
top--the constant one,
all of those are optimistic
presumptions that may take
place.
But there's just as many
reasons to think that,
no, things will turn around and
fertility will go back up.
We just don't know the future.
We CAN say that,
by almost any kind of
reasonable assumption,
for the next 40 years at least,
we're in for a very significant
increase in population that is
going to happen.
How does one--trying to make
this lecture at least somewhat
about the environment.
How does one relate this
population increase to
environmental destruction to
decay of the environment?
This is not an easy question.
There's so many variables
between human population and
environmental destruction that
it's hard to pick out what's
just due to the population.
The simplest statement that you
can make is that the total human
environmental footprint,
footprint is an idea come up by
I guess some en-- I don't know.
Is there a name attached to who
came up with the use of the word
footprint?
Anyway, the idea of the total
environmental impact of an
individual,
a city, a country,
an industry,
whatever,
the environmental footprint is
what's said.
In the simplest way of thinking
about it, the environmental
footprint is proportionate to
the number of people.
Each of the people on earth
have an average footprint,
the more people,
the bigger the footprint.
And that holds at any level,
any assumptions you want to put
on it.
More people,
bigger footprint,
so that's fairly obvious.
It doesn't tell you an awful
lot and so,
many years ago,
a guy named John Holdren
proposed a sort of expansion of
that idea and he is now
Obama's--
the Director of the Office of
Science and Technology,
just recently appointed by
President Obama.
So, at least now,
you have someone in power who
thinks about population.
What he came up with was this
equation,
the impact, the environmental
impact,
he breaks it down and he says
you don't have to worry only
about population but how rich is
that population,
there's a difference between
rich people and poor people.
What about the technology
involved?
Affluence is that we clearly
know that rich people consume a
lot more than poor people,
between the poorest groups on
earth and the richest there's a
factor of something like 40
depending on how poor you want
to go and how rich you want to
go.
That number can be almost
anything, but 40 is a reasonable
number to keep in mind,
so affluence is certainly
important.
The amount of money your
population has.
And technology,
so nowadays if we want to knock
down a forest we use bulldozers
and chainsaws,
chainsaws that will cut down a
40 foot tree with one swipe.
Clearly that technology allows
you to have a much greater
impact than if you're going out
there with a little hand
hatchet,
or maybe even a stone ax to try
to chop down your tree.
The amount of technology that
one has clearly makes a
tremendous difference on how
much destruction you can do.
What you should notice is that
like all--so this is symbolized
by IPAT, the impact is
population, affluence,
technology all multiplied
together.
You should keep in mind that
this is a tautology.
Tautology means something which
is always true,
the equation is always true,
and you just see that from--
you define population just
people, affluence is the income
per person,
the number of dollars that
person has,
and technology is defined in
this nice way of the impact per
dollar spent.
That's the--how you're defining
these terms,
how you're measuring these
terms, and you'll just notice
that if you cross multiply the
persons and persons cancel out,
the dollars and dollars cancel
out,
so your equation ends up that
the impact is equal to the
impact.
That's the sign of a true
equation, true of hitting
all--it's a tautology,
it's always the case.
I should show you that,
for instance,
this is a standard thing out of
Science magazine,
one of their stories about
population.
What are they doing:
impact, here's the first thing,
they list impact per dollar.
In this case,
the impact they're interested
in is carbon.
So, they're talking about the
carbon budget,
they even use the word budget
for that and it's for each US
dollar.--
This is a global figure they're
going to give,
you but they're calculating it
in US dollars.
For each dollar spent on
something in the world how much
carbon is used?
So that's kilograms of carbon
per dollar and it's about now
about a quarter and it's changed
somewhat over time but not
enormously,
so it's gotten better.
This is--the lower the number
the better that for each dollar
of stuff that you buy there's
basically less carbon used to
make it.
This kind of way of thinking
about environmental impacts is
now actually rather standard and
you really can't avoid this kind
of thinking.
One of the real important
things about this,
that people make mistakes on
all the time,
is that the factors multiply.
That you don't add the
population plus the affluence,
plus the technology,
you multiply them.
One of the--there's a very
important book,
I think it's called
Something New Under The
Sun,
and the guy who wrote it,
Yale tried to hire him as our
environmental historian.
He was adding these factors and
making all kinds of totally
wrong conclusions,
saying that,
well the rate of growth of
affluence is so much and the
rate of growth of population is
so much,
so this one is more important
than that one;
just saying utter nonsense
because he didn't realize the
importance of the fact that--
anything per capita is
multiplied by the total
population to get your global
impact.
The global impact is something,
you're interested in the total
impact,
the total amount of carbon
dioxide,
you're not interested so much
in how much carbon dioxide I put
into the air but how much the
six,
seven billion of us put into
the air.
Now the equation looks simple
and it's always true,
and yet it's not as
straightforward as one would
like,
because people take something
beyond the tautological fact of
it being true.
What this--as I've described
it, what this makes you think
is,
well, an increase in population
is always bad,
it always increases the impact,
an increase of affluence is
always bad,
it always increases the impact,
and improvement in technology
is always bad,
it increases the impact.
That's not true.
As people get richer,
as affluence goes up,
they tend to spend a somewhat
larger fraction of their income
on environmental issues.
That once you have a nice house
and a nice car,
and nice school,
and nice clothing you may
actually want to breathe nice
air,
and look at something green and
have a park to go walk into.
So rich people do indeed spend
more than poor people on
environmental issues,
so affluence can work both ways
and that's very important to
remember.
However you have to step back a
little bit and say,
well in the world what fraction
of our increasing affluence have
we actually spent on the
environment?
We have spent a very small
fraction of it,
so in fact, the overwhelming,
dominant effect of our
affluence has indeed been to
have a greater impact on the
environment and we've
ameliorated that a little bit.
I mean very noticeable,
the rivers in America,
we are a rich place,
rivers are really--
a lot of rivers have been
cleaned up,
a lot of smog has been cleaned
up, so we have made progress in
certain very visible ways.
We've exported a fair amount of
our environmental concerns to
other parts of the world by
having them manufacture stuff
and bringing it in here,
and knocking down their forests
to bring in wood and so forth,
and the Chinese and the
Japanese have done just the same
kind of thing.
Similarly, with technology,
it doesn't always work one way.
Yes, technology allows you to
blow off a mountain top to get
some coal.
You've seen these horrific
pictures of West Virginia and so
forth where a more or less
beautiful mountain that's
covered in trees is just gone,
and all that mountain top
becomes slag and pollutes rivers
and acidifies rivers and does
horrible things,
and you have this ugly,
scarred-up land,
so technology does that.
But also improvement of
technology.
Begins with the mining of
copper;
when you replace copper wires
with fiber optics,
they're made of glass and glass
is made from sand and the
harvesting of sand doesn't do an
awful lot of environmental
destruction.
So, that's an improvement in
the environment and there's a
number of examples of that.
Again you have to ask--cars
are--our current push now to
make cars that use less gas.
So the good that it does use,
it gets you how many--to drive
a mile you use less gas,
not enormously less,
but somewhat less.
Technology can help you,
and again the standard question
is,
has our improvement in
technology over the last 20,
30,40, 50 years,
whatever time window you want
to deal with,
has this allowed us to do more
environmental destruction of the
earth or have we used enough--
a big enough fraction of it to
improve the environment.
Our efficiency of use of the
environment, that the things
have gotten better and the
answer is: there's no question
about what's happened.
You see in this,
again this is more
CO_2 stuff,
that here is the sources of
CO_2 addition into the
air,
which is a very good index of
what's happening in the total
economy.
What you see is the land use,
so land adds into the
CO_2 by--where
deforestation and using wood for
timber and everything.
The amount--the land use,
the changes in land use has not
enormously changed.
The width of that line is more
or less the same over time,
so the change in land use is
putting about the same amount of
carbon into the air as before.
There's a little bit of other
emissions which we don't have to
worry about, but fossil fuel
combustion has just gone up,
up, up, and up.
Whatever the balance of our
affluence and our technology,
whatever the balance,
well we can see that is the
balance of our use between using
it to ameliorate the environment
versus messing up the
environment and we'll come back
to this slide if we have a
chance.
The--in terms of the
efficiency, that first factor,
not the first factor,
the dollars per carbon use that
is here.
Actually the carbon use per
dollar is quite interesting;
it has been coming down.
From 1970 it was about a third
of a kilogram of carbon per
dollar and that's come down to
now something like a quarter of
a kilogram per dollar spent,
and that's just carbon,
so you multiply that by almost
four if you want to measure in
CO_2 because carbon is
about one quarter of each
CO_2 molecule.
It's basically--we know for
each dollar spent we put out two
pounds,
a kilogram of carbon,
so every time you go and buy
something just give them a $1
and say that's two pounds of
carbon I'm putting into--
of carbon dioxide I'm putting
into the atmosphere.
It's a not crazy way of
thinking about things.
What is worrying people now is
that this has been a pretty good
decline,
but actually this is now
turning out to be more
significant than people thought.
The rate of decline here,
that's decline in efficiency of
use of carbon,
was about 1.3% a year.
It's no longer declining and
this seems to have continued.
It's now going up by 0.3%,
3/10ths of a percent a year,
so it looks like the--that
we've picked the easy apples,
the low hanging fruit as they
say, in improving our carbon
efficiency and now we may be
getting worse again.
All of that is about how to
think--
now one of the ways of putting
in a quantitative view of the
relationship between population
and the environmental impact.
There are many,
many other considerations with
the relationship between
population and impact.
One is the expansion of humans
into almost every habitat on
earth.
There's almost no limit to this
so I'll show you some
limiting--some extreme cases of
this.
What's going on?
It's something that Malthus
talked about.
Remember we described what
Malthus said,
he's living in England just
about 1800 and the population
was increasing.
What did they do?
There was farmland,
the best farmland was already
farmed,
but as there were more farmers,
the farmers had to move onto
more marginal land,
less good land.
What he was thinking was that
if there's a law of diminishing
returns,
that you have farmers on good
land,
they're producing so much per
farmer and it's fairly good.
England was not a very poor
place.
As population increases they
have to move onto drier land,
swampier land,
hillier land,
and the production per farmer,
for these new farmers,
is less than those that had the
best land.
While the total production
grows, and remember Malthus
showed a linear rise in total
production,
that with new people total
production grows but population
is growing like this.
Since each new person produces
less than an old person,
he has to farm on worse land
than the earlier farmers,
the average productivity goes
down.
That is a thing that has
happened all through history.
Of course humans when they have
a choice of land,
when they're not crowded,
when nobody else is standing
around they choose the best
land,
the easiest to get along with,
to survive in.
Then what happens is people
move out into less good land.
The pictures I'm going to show
you are from Niger which is in
Sahel,
just south of the Sahara
Desert, it actually sticks up
into the Sahara Desert,
and this is a province of Niger
called Azawakh.
It's a huge province because
there's not many people there,
it's a big thing right on the
edge of the Sahara.
The population is 50,000 people.
In the dry season they have two
wells in the whole--
for that whole huge territory,
for that whole--
for all those 50,000 people
there are only two wells and
only one of them works
regularly.
During the rainy season and
this is what it looks like in
that country.
They have, you can see,
there's no water,
nothing growing in the ground,
some of the trees that can
survive,
grass doesn't survive this,
it's too small and it loses
water, it's gone.
Trees can store water basically
and survive fairly long periods
of drought, so you get some
what's called scrub forest.
In the wet season they're very
joyous,
they have lots of water,
they drink lots of water,
but this is the amount of water
that they have and the people
use it for all their functions.
The animals,
I don't know if you can see an
animal back here,
the animals use it to drink and
relieve themselves and here's
girls washing in this water.
This is in the good time of the
year;
this is the water that they
have to survive on.
The dry season is nine months
long.
You have some rain,
not a lot, but some rain for
three months,
then the dry season is nine
months long, and then this is
the labor value of children.
These young girls must travel
35 miles to one of the two wells
that are available and that's
the average,
depending on where they live,
that they have to walk--
no mechanized transport,
they walk 35 miles and they can
carry back only enough water so
their families can drink one
glass a day.
Remember we used to be told,
it's now shown not to be not
really scientific,
drink eight glasses of water
every day;
they're living on one-eighth of
that amount of water.
You have to ask yourselves,
why do people live in such a
God forsaken place?
This life is so hard and so
miserable, and what is the
answer?
The better places have somebody
on them already.
The story, if you can do the
sort of anthropological history,
is virtually always that this
tribe at one point lived in some
much nicer place.
Some tribe got more populous,
got stronger in one way or
another was more vicious,
and they got pushed out of what
was their original,
aboriginal fairly decent land
onto more marginal land.
While they may have been living
now for hundreds of years,
in a sense, it's not their own
choice to live on such a
miserable part of the world.
When you read I think in
the--The War Before
Civilization,
I gave you some readings in
this book which calculated all
the violence,
it describes some people that
had been pushed out into these
marginal lands by stronger
people,
so it gives you a number of
examples of that.
Of course the big example,
the big modern example is in
America,
that the European settlers
pushed the American Indians,
the Native Americans into
horrible lands.
The stories of pushing the
Cherokees from nice farmland and
nice productive land in say
North Carolina and putting them
into Oklahoma which was half
dry,
or the Apaches and various
Indians pushed them off into the
desert.
You go see how miserably a lot
of the American Indians now live
in the Navajo reservations and
so forth,
and say, my God,
why do they want to live there?
They don't.
They didn't want to live there,
they weren't given a choice,
and they were pushed out.
We're talking about dryness
which is one of the things that
people just absolutely can't
exist without water so this is
really the border of existence.
But, where it's very wet--you
remember you read in Bangladesh
that people living on the mud
flats and the monsoon season
comes in,
the water rises or a flood
comes, and they're just washed
out.
Those people didn't choose to
live there, there's no land
anywhere else,
and so they do whatever they
can.
The Eskimos that live up on the
polar ice cap,
there are some Eskimos that are
constantly--
apparently constantly on the
ice cap and don't have a base on
land.
When we think of people living
in these very marginal
circumstances,
one attributes them then to
these famines;
people who live in this region
have famines every so often.
There's great drought,
as you know,
right now.
Parts of Africa have terrible
drought.
California has a terrible
drought, the Colorado River
Basin is having drought.
So, when this happens,
it's always when--
the people get into great
trouble and they can easily
starve to death and some
advanced countries may,
or may not, send them food,
and sending them food has its
own problems.
It's always attributed to
environmental variability,
to climatic troubles.
No one ever asks the question,
why have these people been
pushed into this incredibly
inhospitable region?
I mean part of the ecology of
that region is you're going to
have droughts every so often and
sometimes they're going to last
for years and be very severe.
In California,
the drought in California has
now lasted for years.
Everything in the environment,
the relationship between the
population and environments is
circular.
That people affect the
environment and the environment
comes and bites them back,
it comes back to them.
Water is one of the key things
and probably what will give out
first when we really reach the
environmental limit,
it will almost certainly be
fresh water.
There is a lot of information
that you can get on this very
easily, it's not secret at all.
There are two sources of water
that humans can use,
which is fresh water.
You can desalinate salt water
but the energy costs are
enormous so it's not--
unless you're an Arab and
sitting on an oil well you
really can't do it in any
reasonable way.
There's renewable water,
which is rain water.
When it rains,
that is renewable.
There's this cycle of it goes
up into the atmosphere and comes
back down as rain.
So you have renewable water
coming eventually into rivers
and in one way or another you
tap the rivers.
Then there's mined water,
when you mine it just like you
mine coal, you dig down and you
suck up the water.
The greatest productivity of a
lot of the farm regions of the
world comes from mined water.
So--the Midwest of the U.S.,
especially as you get further
west in it, does not have enough
rainfall, so they use mined
water.
You probably have heard that
the reason they can use mined
water is that underlying on our
Midwest is what's called the
Ogallala aquifer.
Ogallala is the name of one of
the Indian groups that used to
live there, the Ogallala
aquifer.
The farmers all over the west
there just sink down a tube and
suck up the water.
Well you have to think
of--being a scientist you always
want to know how why,
where, all this kind of stuff,
and since a kid you read about
Artesian wells,
and wells to underground water.
Then, eventually,
you ask yourself,
how does water get into rock?
The reason is it drips in there.
The Ogallala aquifer actually
filled from the melt-off of the
last ice age.
Apparently the peak of the last
ice age was about 18,000 years
ago and then it took about 8,000
years to melt until something
like 10,000 years ago,
those are very approximate
numbers.
For 8,000 years ice was
melting, the ground was soggy,
and drip, drip,
drip.
Rock is never totally solid,
there's always somewhere,
some little crack and the water
slowly drips through the cracks
and goes in it.
Any kind of--When the rocks get
folded, there's caverns in there
and any kind of space eventually
water will find its way in.
If you ever paid attention to
the roof on your house,
you know that water gets in,
no matter what you do.
It's the filling of these
aquifers.
I don't know--I can't remember
when that ice age started,
but something that took 8,000
years to fill,
but that depended on a glacier
which was there for the previous
10,000 years.
So, we're talking about a
resource that is one of the
shorter term resources and it's
something like it fills in
20,000 years.
Now we're sucking it up in
decades and it's very much going
way down.
There were some slides,
and the reason I was a little
late,
I could not find the slides
this morning,
I had them yesterday and I
don't know where they went,
so I didn't put them on but
they showed some interesting
kinds of things.
That when you're sitting on top
of this aquifer you've got the
rock and the water,
water is incompressible so it
holds up the rock.
You suck out the water there's
now a space there,
and what happens,
the rock starts crumbling and
falling down.
What happens is the land
actually falls.
In the pictures that I could
not find,
show first from Houston,
Texas a farm there and it's--
shows you a pump,
it's just a concrete platform
with a pump,
and you know where the land was
and then the land is several
feet beneath that.
The land is just shrunken,
has collapsed.
And the second picture I want
to show is in Galveston,
Texas not so far from Houston,
now the land has fallen,
again all due to irrigation,
but they're near the sea so the
salt water has come in and now
what used to be good
agricultural land is now flooded
with the Gulf of Mexico.
Are you from that region?
She was shaking her head,
as maybe she knows.
The most impressive picture
comes from the San Joaquin
Valley of California.
Now, you know probably--That's
where all our fruits and
vegetables come from,
that's a huge source of
American food supply.
Probably almost all of you
today have already today eaten
something that was farmed in the
San Joaquin.
Anybody from that part?
Nobody from--we don't have
enough farmers at Yale.
Well this is a picture of a
pole that they put in to measure
the drop of the land.
What you see is this very large
pole and a man,
the man is sort of down here.
What the pole is,
is the top of the pole is where
the land was in--
I can't remember like 1957 or
something like that and the land
has dropped 30 feet in that time
and the man is now 5.5 foot man
or a six foot man,
is a small fraction of this
pole.
It's really a shocking kind of
photo, and of course the
agricultural activity in the
valleys of California has only
increased since then.
The amount of water pumped has
increased and the land keeps
falling at a very noticeable
rate, so it's a very graphic
thing.
Now, from when you suck out the
water,
it takes quite a while for the
rock to sort of collapse and
fall down because it's got some
structural strength to it.
If you can see how the much the
land has fallen,
you can just imagine how much
the water table itself has
fallen,
many times more than the actual
land has fallen.
In some places you can measure
this fairly readily.
In parts of Texas and Arizona
water tables have dropped
hundreds of feet,
even in northwest of Chicago
there's been a 200 to 300 foot
drop in the water table,
just sucking it out.
Three quarters of Texas'
irrigated area water tables are
falling and this is true all
over the world.
I mean the United States is
very technological so we do a
lot of drilling,
but the north China plain,
which is,
again, where the wheat in China
is grown,
drops 40 inches every year.
Tamil Nadu in India,
southern India,
another very productive part of
the world, 100 inches a year the
water tables are falling.
There's a study that just came
out--in February,
which measures the groundwater
levels that are coming--of the
water coming out of the
Himalayas.
So, the Himalayas,
as you know,
sit right in the center of Asia
and the Yellow River and the
Yangtze River sort of feed
China,
and you have the Helmand River
feeds Afghanistan,
the Indus River feeds Pakistan
and the Ganges River feeds north
India and you've got the Ganges
goes into Bangladesh,
the Brahmaputra,
the Meghna all feed the
Bangladesh area,
then you have the Mekong,
and the Salween,
and the Irrawaddy,
which do Vietnam and Thailand,
and Cambodia,
and Burma, so all of these come
out of the Himalaya mountains.
What's happening?
The groundwater in these
regions is going down 2 to 4
meters a year so that's 6 to
12,13 feet every year the water
table goes down.
Venice is sinking for similar
reasons;
it's much smaller,
only 9 inches in the whole
century.
Bangkok is sinking 13
centimeters a year.
Mexico City--I hope I have
those slides here.
Mexico City is sinking in a
drastic way there's very--since
it's so prominent there's very
good data from Mexico City.
Mexico City put in a subway,
a wonderful subway,
if--I had a young lady with me
when I was in the subway;
aside from getting squeezed you
get groped in the Mexico City
subway.
They laid it flat,
but now with the ground--
the sucking out of the water
the ground is sinking and it
doesn't sink evenly,
so now the subway is like this
and some of it that was
underground is now above ground
because the ground has just
sunken away from the subway.
The sewers and the water supply
have exactly the same problem.
Water--in Mexico City,
the city itself has sunk 30
feet from when the subway was
originally put down.
Water pipe that was laying flat
on the ground in 1934 is now 26
feet over everyone's head and
some suburbs are sinking about
two feet every year.
Student:  How come all
this stuff doesn't also just
sink down evenly?
Prof: Because it's
all--it's uneven and I don't
really know the answer to that.
The question is why doesn't
everything sort of just sink
evenly?
It just doesn't happen,
so a flat subway ends up like
this.
Student:  Like the pole
in California,
why doesn't it just sink to the
ground?
What is it attached too?
Prof: I don't know how
they arranged that pole,
you would think everything
would sink, yes I don't know.
They may--I don't know,
just don't know the answer.
In Mexico City the water
supply, as more water is pumped,
of course the city--the rate of
pumping is faster,
the city sinks faster and
there's--the pipes eventually
get twisted and they rupture so
there's now 40,000 repaired--
ruptures that they repair each
year and many more that they--
they're not even reported and
they don't get around to
repairing them.
Apparently one-third of the
water in the system leaks out,
and a lot of the city lies
below the sewer lines now,
so the sewage doesn't leave the
city any more,
it collects in pools,
and they have now had to
construct vast pumping stations
to pump it out--
the sewage back out from these
pools.
They have--they're building a
whole new, much deeper sewage
system, they're building 124
miles of 80 foot sewers.
That's enough of that.
I think you get the message
here.
Let me have a few more minutes.
I put in your reading and just
something that you may think,
well, why did he put that in,
is how much is being paid for
caviar and fish and things like
that.
Its part of a longer piece that
I'm not going to have time talk
about,
but there's a lot of fish in
the sea,
but there's a lot of people
that want to eat fish,
so fishing is one of those
industries that's really just
cleaning out the sea of fish.
When there were small boats,
things were okay,
the fish could regenerate.
But now Korea,
and East Germany,
and Japan have these huge,
huge ships that have
miles--their nets are miles and
miles long and they just suck
everything out of the sea so the
fish are disappearing.
You'd think that economically
that as the fish disappear,
and even when they can't
reproduce themselves,
it would get the--uneconomical
to catch the fish anymore.
In actual fact what happens is
that,
in the fishing,
there's presumably good fish
that people like to eat,
and what happens is,
as those get fished out you go
down to the next level of fish.
If you've been going to
restaurants a while you see
this, every couple of years
there's some new fish on the
menu that I've never heard of.
Have you had that experience?
That's because the fish that
you ate two or three years are
now gone because they've been
fished out, so the quality of
the fish goes down and down.
If people have money,
they still want to buy the
better quality fish and it turns
out they will pay almost
anything for this better quality
fish.
What happens is then,
instead of the economics
working for you,
that as it gets more expensive
to catch fish,
you let off on the fish,
the price of the fish goes up,
so that it's still worthwhile
to catch those fish.
What happens then that
the--because of that economics,
the pressure to catch these
fish to extinction keeps up
there and some of the outrageous
prices that I gave you,
that's the point of that kind
of stuff.
What you should realize is that
environmental destruction is
essentially--most of it--a lot
of it is irreversible.
Loss of species is
irreversible,
I mean if you want to wait
hundred million years,
yes species will differentiate
and you'll get new species but
that's basically irreversible.
Things like fishing out various
species in the sea so that they
don't recover is an irreversible
kind of thing.
Loss of habitat is generally
irreversible.
I think I described to you
northeast of Brazil where,
or all of Brazil,
all of any jungle region where
the whole ecosystem is kept
going by the amount of fungi
that recycle the nutrients in
the jungle.
When you cut down the trees the
sun beats down,
kills the fungi,
you no longer have this mat of
fungi,
so now something falls into it,
it doesn't get decomposed,
the nutrients don't go back
into the trees.
The whole land dries out and
becomes what they call laterite
which is hard soil,
hard like rock soil,
and it's not clear that that
ever,
ever can recover.
Fish stocks.
The cod stocks declined like
20,30 years ago and they really
have not come back,
even though they've really cut
down the fishing and banned it
mostly,
they're not coming back.
There's apparently too small of
a population for the
reproduction system to work
well.
Because this is irreversible,
because--this is a very
important point,
because environmental damage is
irreversible as population
increases.
As the world economy increases,
the pressure on the environment
gets worse and worse.
You can imagine a nice scenario
where eventually population
comes down and maybe some of the
pressure is let off.
But, what you'll have to worry
about is that peak because the
things that are going to
disappear irreversibly,
your species,
your habitat,
your so forth depend not on the
level now,
but on the maximum demand.
That once the maximum--When and
if the maximum demand comes off
it's ok.
What we have to worry about is
this peak size of population and
other demands on the
environment.
it's this peak size that
becomes important.
We've seen the great range of
variability in the UN
projections.
We could reach a peak at a
billion more people,
or two billion,
or three, or four,
or five,
or six, or seven,
or 12, or who knows how many
more billions and which of those
curves happens is not going to
be a random event.
It depends on what humans do
right now.
Because of momentum,
the people that are born now
are going to have children and
they're a cumulative factor in
the environment.
So whatever the birth rate now
is,
whatever the population growth
rate is now,
if that eventually stops
there's still momentum for
another 100 or 150 years.
I showed you the data from
various countries showing that,
even after they reach
replacement level fertility,
their population grows for
another 100 years or so forth.
Again, what we do now
determines the maximum
environmental destruction that's
going on.
I think one of the most
important points is that
environmental solutions are
difficult.
It is not an easy job to fix
the environment.
Like global warming,
there's huge arguments whether
we should try to prevent or
should we just try to adapt it,
and I think half your courses
in the Forestry School are,
'No.
It's better to let it happen
and it's going to be cheaper to
adapt to it."
And the other half of the
courses are saying "It's a
horrible thing,
we've got to try to prevent
it."
Mostly, like using solar power,
wind power--
the costs--nuclear power even,
the costs are so very high that
with current technology the
alternatives are really not
feasible.
What's happening is,
China is building a new coal
plant every week.
They would love to reduce their
pollution.
They've done whatever they can.
But their population is still
growing, they have that huge
poor population,
they need the energy.
They have no choice now but to
build power plants.
What do you tell the Chinese to
do?
No, you people should keep
being poor, don't build the coal
power plants.
Well we don't say that and
they're not going to do it
anyway, because their people
demand some decent standard of
living, which requires energy.
So the CO_2 in the
air goes crazy.
There are no easy fixes for the
environment from that kind of
side.
It's a really very hard job.
The only success that one could
really claim in the last say 50
years for what you might call
the environmental movement is
the population,
is on the population front.
You've seen,
I've shown you many,
many times that around the
third world,
up until 1950,1960,
the birthrate was six,
seven, eight people--children
per woman and now it's dropped
to below half that,
in fact to about 2.8.
So it's something like less
than half of that;
enormous progress in that area.
I've shown you again in many
different ways that people want
fewer children in every country,
every developing country of the
world.
You ask, how many they want
and--you find out how many they
have.
In every country the number
that they're having is above
what they want and massive
effects.
There's usually--like Bolivia
which is not one of your most
advanced countries,
and universally around the
world 70%,
80% of the women want to not
have children.
70% just totally don't want it;
another 10%--well not in the
next two years.
The technology we have,
condoms are not wonderful,
birth control pills are not
wonderful,
and they're not wonderful,
but they're good enough to do
the job.
Population is the rare issue
where a lot has been done and a
lot can be done.
We don't have to win the hearts
and minds of the people;
they're already telling us they
want fewer children than they're
having.
We don't need new technology.
It's dirt cheap compared to
the--compared to getting rid of
carbon in the atmosphere or
reducing it.
It's dirt cheap,
I mean a cycle of pills on the
world market is $0.80,
a diaphragm is a $1.25,
I mean we're talking dirt
cheap.
The medical knowledge to
provide these things is almost
at the barefoot doctor level so
you don't need very highly
trained personnel,
and as I mentioned to you,
labor and even educated labor
in the developing countries is
cheap.
Of all the possible things one
can do to improve the
environmental situation,
it looks to me like encouraging
the continued decline of
fertility is the easiest thing.
You don't have to spend a lot
of money,
most of the people in the world
will be 'Yeah,
rah, rah, I want that,' and
we've seen from Ryerson's
lecture here that with a very
little bit--
I mean he puts on one soap
opera which runs for two,
three times a week for like a
year which is significant but
very small intervention and very
cheap,
and the number of people going
to family planning clinics
doubles and triples and it
just--
an incredible amount of
progress with a very small
input,
so this is a very,
very doable thing.
We have a long way to go.
The fertility,
as I've said,
has come down from six,
seven, and eight to 2.6 as a
global average but 2.6 is still
a 30% increase every generation.
Population growth,
I've just showed you is about a
billion people every 13 years
now.
It's still very high.
Bringing it down further is
probably the only feasible,
reasonably realistic thing that
one can do to massive--
I mean the environment is going
to hell at such a massive rate
--
we need some massive change and
I don't think anything else
comes close to what you can do
with population.
I challenge the
environmentalists all the time,
and I say, look every 13 years
there's another billion people.
Add up all the
environmental--all that
conservation,
that environmentalists have
ever done,
all the restoration,
add that up and compare that to
a footprint of a billion people
in 13 years.
It's not in the same--you're
just not in the same ballpark
and yet that message doesn't get
through.
There's a wonderful quote,
and this is (maybe the--
cameras don't even want it),
that Peter Beard,
who's one of the most famous
conservation writers in Africa
and he's very outspoken and does
not use polite language all the
time.
This is a quote from him,
"I broke my ass to do
these conscientious books."
He did all kinds of books on
the environment in Africa.
"But the public's not
getting it at all.
You show them photographs of
30,000 carcasses with the ivory
tusks still in place,"
that's elephants--
30,000 ivory elephants,
"And the tusks are still
in place and they try to tell
you that we should prosecute
poachers"
as if that was the issue.
"Doesn't anyone realize
that people are hungry and using
these animals for food?
People still think its wild
Africa.
Doesn't anyone realize that
this is all about population
pressure?
What the"--and he uses the
'F' word, "What the 'F's'
going on out there in the
CONservation word?"
He capitalizes "con"
as for con job,
"Nothing but lies,
fundraising lies."
I think we are--I mean he
overstates things,
and as you know,
that's one of my pedagogical
tools is to engage somewhat in
overstatement.
You remember it though.
The whole environmental
movement has got its head in the
sand about the one thing that
could really probably make a big
difference.
Just to conclude,
the earth is in a big race.
I've shown you population is
increasing, environmental
problems are increasing,
but fertility is coming down.
Depending on how these two
countervailing forces work,
in the future we will either
come to a smooth landing,
a soft landing,
that fertility will come down
fast enough that takes the
pressure off the increasing
environmental issues,
or it won't,
or population won't come down
fast enough.
Then we're off into who knows
what.
That's I think what to take
away from this course,
the tremendous race between the
increase of population,
a billion people every 13
years, the decline in fertility,
a decline since 1960 in about
40,50 years declined to more
than half.
How is that race going to be
won and what are we--which side
is going to win that race and
what can we politically--what
can we do about it?
Have a good summer and have a
good test.
>